[MUSIC]
I want to know defeat People call me a demon king My old friend You
no longer see me as a human
That's why I
[Applause] I've
come to wish to be defeated I'm a bad
loser  If you look
at it, you'll recognize me as a human being,
so [MUSIC] There's no one left who can beat me, and
my life
seems to have turned to sin
[MUSIC]
But in the afterlife,
I can enjoy a different fate
[Music]
Then it's
reincarnation.
It's like, time flies so
fast I'm so glad you're our son
Wow, thank you
Father,
mother Even
though you're my son, you
look handsome to
him You're your son
Jack
, I used to be called the Demon King in secret, but I don't
care, I live in a rural town.
It seems that his level has
declined considerably since my time.In
addition, he
seems to have been blessed with good health, physical strength, and motor nerves, and he has
improved his martial arts without much difficulty.
Is it a
dream?
[Music]
Yes,
I have dreams and
ambitions It's been
10 years since I've been reincarnated I'm
mentally and physically
fit to form a bond of friendship
You can say you've grown into a
human Find someone who doesn't look at me with awe
and make friends on an equal footing
Why are you so strong?
But now times have changed and
I'm just Villager A on the 1st floor Do
n't be shy Come on, come
on let's do
whatever you want I wonder
what it's like
Why do I say this?The
dignity that cannot be hidden even after reincarnation
intervenes in their deep psyche and prevents them from approaching them.
Hey,
what is this pressure? It's stupid
, even when I've met the gods I didn't even have the
slightest fear
[music]
It's amazing that I've been cornered so far
But
I used to be called a demon king
I can't let this man-like crisis come to the fore Get
out of here Those who are in trouble
Well, you responded to my voice
I'll praise
you.  Let's do it,
my name is
Demon King Barbatos, I've usurped your nations,
I'm proud of my heroes, and
I've destroyed the gods.
I made a
deal and offered
a deal What more do you want
?  Mr. Art, you
seem to be in a bad mood
, don't you think you've forgotten the face of the village chief
? Are you
friends with
Allhide?  I feel like
I'm exhausted
Let me teach you one simple method Is it a
spell?
[MUSIC]
So, Mr. Ard, when
it comes to friends,
I follow my son
.
I understand your concern, we are the same.
Would you mind being a tomato on stilts?
Let's do it, but this is the world
No,
calm
down, calm down Ard Mediol
Who are red and chaos
?  But get
angry
and
burn everything down What's the matter?
Before he even became a troubled partner, was that a relief
?
Because of the bullying at that time,
the backbiting caused my daughter to completely close her heart.
I don't think there's anything I can do about my bloodline, and
there's less of a glance here than in Auto.It
's a good decision to come back
.
No,
I didn't mean to surprise
you What are you
?
If it's a counterproductive rhetoric that you can see and see,
I'm afraid to say it, but I think I'm still lacking in power
and I think there's room for calculation.
Would you
be
so
kind as to
close the distance?
I'm sure we'll be able to understand each other and improve each other I think we
'll have a wonderful relationship So don't
be silly I can understand It's
impossible
[music]
Why?
I called you the beautiful you,
but I
heard from my father, so even so, the
world is small, isn't it?
My parents and my best friend, the All-
Hide 5-speed
, how are you and Irina-san?
I tried to maintain a calm and gentlemanly attitude, and if I
do that, I'm sure we'll develop friendships someday.
[Music]
Happy birthday,
Irina.  Hey,
I know everything about you
That
's the number of moles I ca
n't let this chance to be friends with her
Why are you here
Irina  I know you're mad at monsters, so
I
went to pick you up. Your
trees are beautiful, aren't you,
Irina?  It's still beautiful
, I'll never give up The
good mood strategy does
n't seem to have the effect of making the current situation look like a
cemetery.
I feel like something like this happened in my previous life.
Jack,
please help me.
Please leave it to me Allhide Bridge I will definitely
bring Irina home Mr. Heard
What do you say
?
You've come to
such a reversal of the economy I'm a goblin inside
I can resist and enjoy
[music]
Why don't you call
me out?
You can
do whatever you like
[Music
] You called my name for the first time,
Irina-san.
Of course, it's to help Irina-san.
You can't
even lay a finger on me, let alone Irina-san
.
[Applause]
Let the ax devour the choice [music] Heard's still ain't back He'll be fine Ard
You promised to bring Irina back
So Irina's okay
Oh yeah his flying magic I don't think so
Lost Skill
Irina, are you okay?
Why did you save me? I died.
Please don't say such sad things
if you don't mind I know how you feel I'm
alone and lonely and
painful and
sad
But
if it's the pain that loneliness brings, I understand better than anyone
That's why
I want to be your friend.
I will
never betray my friends again Because
I once
betrayed my best friend
So this time I
want to make a lasting friendship without hurting you
But I'm sure I'm
worse than him
I don't care I'm
selfish
I'm stupid and it's boring to be with you That's
not the case In
fact, I really enjoy talking to Irina
Someday,
someday, there will come a time when you hate me It's impossible
But I'm
really
[music]
really  You will be friends with
me No matter what happens,
I will never betray you or hate you In
the name of Demon King Barbatos
[Music]
What
about
Barbatos?  Barbatos, the demon king of the world
, got a lifelong friend and lived
happily ever after
.
Let's enter magic school
[music]
Who called me to melt this child
Longing for warmth
[applause]
[music]
hugging me together
]
[music]